el ejercicio militar entre ambas
naciones más grande de su historia
Estados Unidos y filipinas dan inicio al
balicatán que en 2023 verá desplegados a
más de 18.000 soldados de ambos países
los ejercicios finalizarán el 28 de
abril 17 días en los que se realizarán
maniobras con munición Real además de la
simulación de un asalto con cohetes para
hundir barcos el balicatán tendrá lugar
en el mar del sur de China y en el
estrecho de Taiwán zonas de alta tensión
por la influencia china
Estados Unidos y filipinas comparten una
visión de indopacífico libre abierto
próspero seguro resiliente y más
conectado cada uno de ustedes de pie
cada uno de nosotros de pie hombro con
hombro balicatán ayuden a hacer realidad
esta visión
Aunque filipinas es una Aliado
tradicional de Estados Unidos no todos
están contentos con el balicatán decenas
de ciudadanos protestaron contra los
ejercicios argumentando que Washington
está usando a mano y la para demostrarle
su poderío militar a China
está claro que estos juegos de guerra
pretenden proyectar el poder de Estados
Unidos en Asia no están pensados para
defender a filipinas ni para ayudar al
país a modernizarse
[Música]
están pensados para mostrar el poder
estadounidense y es una guerra de
preparación filipinas se verá finalmente
arrastrada a este tipo de conflicto que
no es necesariamente de nuestro interés
días después de los ejercicios chinos en
el estrecho de Taiwán ahora Estados
Unidos parece entrar en una carrera de
disuasión militar con el gigante
asiático